okay do you want to talk about tiffany
haddish getting asked about her uh her
costume
yo i love you
a little costume change
um i'm not wearing a costume i'm wearing
dolce gabbana
it's called an evening gown darling
this is not no one's paying me for this
i paid for it it's custom thank you time
of death for me right now you look
gorgeous i'm not acting this is my life
this is what fame looked like
this was success looked like
that's what money looked like this is
what it looked like it's what it looked
like
when is your book coming out called this
what it looked like and i will just read
the entire that book's not coming no
time soon but i curse you with joy will
be out in november okay okay and later
the last black unicorn will be out next
month i'm doing so much right now okay
i'm just you know trying to accomplish a
lot of things before 50.
what are you doing well i'm wondering
something i'm here with no shoes on i'm
jealous
here's the thing i'm from chicago and
you out here with no shoes on this is
warm weather to me i know it's hot out
here to you right
she was actually sweet with her then she
was
no that was shade that was shaking
absolutely look at
she's like what the [ __ ] you doing
barefoot yeah on the street
why did she think that's disgusting
why did she even say costume when would
you even say that she misspoke
costume change and wardrobe change are
so
they're close come on
costume change you do it theatrical
performances wardrobe change like a
wedding event so this is only racist
because she's black
wait who's that where is it yeah is
there evidence no no that's what it is i
think they're trying to yeah yeah yeah
that's what that was they're saying that
this race is they're saying it's racist
because she's a black woman so she's
wearing a costume where if it was some
white actress she'd be wearing her
wardrobe
i didn't take it that way outfit change
oh good i'm glad yeah i got to get out
of this racist mentality yeah yeah you
did well then why is this a big [ __ ]
deal
that's what i found that should be more
insulting to dolce gabbana than her
why'd she take it personal
no she just like don't call my clothes a
costume also why would you say why would
she pay for that why can't you just tell
dolce gabbana where you [ __ ] to the
office yeah maybe there's no way in the
house
oh maybe they didn't want a dresser yeah
that's it don't wear their [ __ ] that's
on them they also were cancelled a while
ago
yeah that's true when they had like what
they have on their [ __ ]
it was like crazy
was that the ones that had like the
little black kids wearing the crazy
sweaters oh
yeah not like with china
i just wish she stopped a little bit
earlier like she could have did just a
couple burns and then just like kept it
moving yeah but it went a little too
long i don't think it was that bad y'all
think it was bad
she said i slept
[Applause]